je reconnais que les gains à une voix
absolument formidable et du talent où je
me suis insurgés c'est quand j'ai vu
apparaître sur les murs pour les pour
remplir les zénith sur une affiche comme
ça sur instagram vous l'aviez commencer
la voix de johnny hallyday à la halle
jean baptiste guégan j'ai trouvé ça
scandaleux fossat d'escroquerie ce n'est
pas bien puisse se faire du mal à
l'artiste en l'occurrence droit je
trouve formidable revanche sa carrière
est il maintenant il fait ses trucs en
plus ça le mixage est ici je trouve ça
un peu dur là ce que non il a raison
mais j'ai pas d'accord avec lui ça fait
jamais de mal à l'artiste en europe il
ya à peu près une cinquantaine de sosie
de claude françois il y en a une
quarantaine de journalistes non mais
faut savoir combien des voix soit on est
saisie vocale soit on peut être sosie
physique
c'est une demande du public c'est à dire
qu'un anglais on a envie de revoir ce
rêve de l'avenue jean baptiste il a
l'envié guégan a répondu il a dit qu'il
n'avait jamais validé cette affiche jean
baptiste mais bon est-ce que john il
avait parlé de guingamp qu'est-ce qu'ils
ne connaissaient non parce qu'au départ
c'était un fan de johnny hallyday il a
grandi avec les chansons de johnny et il
a jamais fréquenté ce métier avant
finalement la disparition du chanteur du
guide et moi je vois qu'un phénomène et
pendant de comparer et je trouve qu'en
gestion carrière aussi s'en sort c'est
que pour moi maître gims c'est un peu
jonna lee
johnny hallyday noir c'est à dire que
c'est des phénomènes où tous les
français moi je vais devoir mettre guim
son célèbre de france
alors je vous interromps ce que la
carrière un peu jeune encore games
online et star jeudi au stade de france
mais il sait c'est divin mais il est sa
carrière est jeune encore là mais je
veux dire nomen cd phénomène de société
mais après moi ce qui me fait rire
pardon sûr car vu juste moi j'adore les
artistes qui vieillissent parce qu'en
fait tu as me dois plus rien à personne
et parler avec son coeur
bigard moi qui pète les plombs sur
france bleu s'agira les drire pendant
une semaine ça
voilà s'arrêter plus avec nous
demandèrent c'est un mec je voulais le
dire
la plainte du maurice qui ont taclé je
voulais dire à jean marie bigard et je
le dis ce soit un amour de mal à enfin
arrêter de dire que jean marie bigard il
est ringard il a cessé de quelques une
star à la johnny dans les mangas sur une
forêt ce pays est paré des anciens mais
bon là il pète les plombs le confinement
lui a fait le plus grand bien
cg chialer parce que même l'animatrice
est d'accord jean marie calme-toi on est
avec toi mais je veux dire que ces mecs
là il parle maintenant avec le coeur
parce que comme disait il ils ont plus
rien à prouver en fait la performance du
jeune et l'idée c'est d'avoir traversé
le temps il a une feuille le sait bien
quand on commence une carrière on sait
pas si ça va durer trois ans gardée par
une chroniqueuse était de 57 ans enfin
c'est on ne peut pas le savoir au début
mais si tu peux passer aucun droit à
droite s'exprimer aussi évident de
comprendre que jean claude camus a a
passé toute sa vie avec johnny hallyday
là qu'il est complètement et cc après
c'est un travail ce2 qui ont formé tout
ça et que quelque part on voit ce jeune
homme aussi guégan il a il a énormément
de talent non sucré on imprime à défaut
c'est le comprendre les juke r b r il a
vendu le même nicolas pernikoff 2002 où
vous savez très bien qu'ils avaient une
particulière et il a l'air énervé aussi
c'était qu'il avait un d'une doublure de
voix en permanence chanter et oui quand
même ils pas rentrés en chinois
regardent ailleurs linda l'époque mama
je crois mamma mia qui avait fait une
reprise de mamma mia ou et jean claude
camus ne voulait pas que ses doublures
de voix puisse avant dé se mettre à
l'avant de la scène
donc je veux dire c'est danser ça a été
quand jean denis et jean claude camus
ont toujours eu ses relations avec ces
voix qui était un peu sourire et puis
jean baptiste et puis je pense que ce
sens jean claude camus y aurait pas eu
le johnny déchets réaliser les rêves ont
fait un énorme rogers